I want to apologize for this we've been
very busy doing these shows I did not
get to eat lunch today I didn't have a
chance so I just take a sink would you
could someone bring me out a sandwich
please
I just want to I love to eat thank you
and thank you for bringing them through
those space-age doors yeah it's great
you just applauded a sandwich
that's how good the comic-con crowds are
yeah sandwich in there it was wait a
minute this sandwich is huge there's no
way I can eat this whole thing huh I
need to cut it in half and if you have a
knife they don't let me have knives okay
that's right me neither I guess I'll
just have to throw it in the trash I
mean there's nothing else they can do oh
just just a spruce you got it for you
you're right hey Bruce can you please
come out here
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up ginger well I need to cut the
sandwich I wonder if he could maybe give
me a hand
sure how about that hand yeah you better
step back a little girl all right you
crusty son of a
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Bruce that's
Loran tastic thank you you're welcome
you're welcome if there's anything else
you need I'll be in my dressing room
just polishing the old blade if you know
what I mean
of course I mean masturbate
these second season am ash vs. Evil Dead
premiere time starts this October
[Music]
you